nein nein die verkehrsregeln in
brasilien sind genauso wie die in
deutschland allerdings glaube ich dass
die leute in sao paulo sich nicht so
genau daran halten
der straßenverkehr ist da viel
chaotischer die fahrräder wahrscheinlich
nicht ganz ordentlich unvergleichlicher
video muss dass bei dieser unbedingt mut
macht ich glaube er weiß noch nichts von
dem unfall
wir sind riesa ist ein ganz netter
doch doch natürlich weiß er bescheid ich
finde es ganz wichtig dass man immer die
wahrheit sagt das allerdings war da
sieht man wieder das lehrt die
ehrlichkeit und vertrauen universell
sind
ich war nur acht papa jetzt das wieder
gut sein
habt ihr doch schon gesagt dass ich
nicht wieder tun werde mein vater regt
sich darüber auf dass ich hier nichts
vom vorsprechen erzählte meine ich rege
mich nicht auf ich bin enttäuscht dass
meine tochter lieber brotlose kunst
studieren die weltstadt eine banklehre
zu machen ich ihnen noch anbieten
das weiß ich noch nicht hier gibt es
auch noch so viele andere schöne sachen
was ist das denn dafür eine wurst was
ist los auf eine rheinische kaffeetafel
gehören wie ein kuchen auch wurst und
käse und schwarzbrot
nachdem es ist lustig wir in brasilien
mission das auch dauernd es gibt ganz
viele speisen die gleichzeitig süß und
sauer sind sagt sauer oder herzhaft
vielleicht ja genau herzhaft sagen sie
ja was mich interessieren würde
was sagen ihre eltern eigentlich davon
dass ich jedoch schon
die kosten gegeben ich habe noch zu
hause vielleicht ein freunde wisst ihr
noch bestimmt sehr verlassen
hinein in brasilien habe ich kein freund
aber hier also irgendwie zumindest
versucht seit tagen verzweifelt einen
jungen zu treffen den sie im internet
kennengelernt hat klappt nicht so dass
sie nach deutschland kommen und hier
ausgerechnet auch die kunsthochschule
gehen ich hätte gedacht dass sie in der
sache nach deutschland kommen für die
das land bekannt ist für die technik die
wirtschaft die kunst herr peters die hat
hier noch eine große tradition
deutschland ist das land der dichter und
denker oder etwa nicht